que deviendront les élèves et leur
famille réfugiés quand l'école Michelet
de Tours aura fermé ses portes pour les
vacances ce vendredi c'est dans cette
école que les enseignants et parents
d'élèves du collectif pas d'enfants à la
rue et berges en urgence les familles
qui sont autres solutions serait
contrainte de dormir dehors les besoins
sont importants c'est au total sans
nuité qui ont été possibles depuis la
création du collectif en mars vendredi
les portes de l'école resteront donc
clauses pour les congés d'été le
collectif réclame la mise à disposition
de locaux appartenant à l'État
franklavel
pas d'enfants à la rue mais pour combien
de temps demain soir l'école Michelet
fermera ses portes pour deux mois le
temps des vacances d'été les jeunes
élèves et leurs familles s'en domicile
qui étaient mises à l'abri danser locaux
doivent maintenant trouver un autre toit
une situation qui désespère Aurélie
Ardoin enseignante dans cette école et
membre du collectif pas d'enfants à la
rue on a obtenu que les personnes les
familles soutenues par le collectif soit
hébergé en priorité mais on sait très
bien que notre famille qui sont sortis
du dispositif puisque c'est un jeu de
chaise musicale il y a une scolarité
obligatoire dès lors qu'on est sur le
sol français mais le droit au logement
n'est pas respecté pour pallier la
fermeture estivale de l'école ses
membres manifestaient hier afin de
réclamer la réquisition de logements
vides appartenant à l'État celui-ci est
inoccupé depuis le 30 juin il y a des
sanitaires il y a l'électricité
c'est à l'abri en ces temps d'insécurité
la nuit dans les rues de la ville il est
plus important que jamais de pouvoir
mettre à l'abri des enfants qui dorment
dans les parcs du Sanitas notamment et
ce bâtiment nous semble tout à fait
adaptés en trois mois d'existence le
collectif a déjà permis d'organiser plus
de 100 nuités contactez la préfecture
n'a pas donné suite à nos demandes